how's it going bros my name is PewDiePie
and welcome to Friday and it's not a
Friday but what are you gonna do that's
my problem
speaking about problems we all have them
doesn't matter who you think of you
might be fangirling over someone that
you just think it's perfect in every
single way they're beautiful they're
funny they're smart they're just so
attractive that your panties drop and
that person is me but I still have
problems for example here's mine and
even this guy has a problem he keeps
pooping on the carpet but that's beside
the point
I wanted to dedicate today's video by
helping you bros out so I asked you to
tweet me on Twitter what your problem is
and I'm gonna try and solve them at the
best of my abilities for you you're
welcome
all right first off I have three
testicles while it's always good to keep
a spare my poop is yellow are you sure
you're not just peeing my ps4 won't fit
in the freezer what am I supposed to do
obviously you make it into an ice cream
and then you smear it over your body
because ps4 makes great body lotions
great it's already trending the hashtag
when will my selfie game reach this
level I mean this is top level right it
won't happen
I'm sorry wait was that Professor Snape
do we have some actual questions in here
I am a vegetarian but I want to eat your
face hello 911 to report a vegetarian
yes yes he is trying to eat my face
you're taking care of it thank you I
tricked snuffing here man you might you
have a lot of problems I accidentally
ate a live hamster and I can now feel it
crawling inside my stomach what do I do
eat yourself see what happens that way
you can feel yourself crawl in your
stomach instead my crush doesn't love me
and isn't gay what should I do
just tell everyone that he's gay and
move on with your life what makeup do
you wear to make yourself look so
natural actually use a great product
it's called no makeup I am actually
applying it to my face right now as we
speak it's very effective you really get
that no makeup look that we all want and
you just look fabulous
my dog is more attractive than me I
would recommend marrying your dog and
live a happy life I want a cat but my
parents are allergic what you do is you
take a little bit of their hair and you
chop it down into tiny tiny tiny tiny
pieces and then you sniff it and then
you're a wizard I'm better than everyone
and it's getting boring well you could
just chop off on all your limbs and that
way you have more of a challenge is this
how you make hot dogs no you put them in
the oven obviously god I put on some
Kardashian products and my skin fell off
what do I do
don't worry all you have to do is find a
way to make your body grow really really
big and then you can cosplay attack on
the Titan I have a bad case of bus
syndrome my face is a butt and so are my
hands and feet wow you make a great
party pooper I'm secretly a spider how
do I tell my friends
you probably shouldn't tell them because
everyone hates spiders consider maybe a
sex change or something I don't know my
vagina is next question my teeth hurt
when I eat rocks hmm just pull out your
teeth and you'd they shouldn't hurt I'm
pregnant but I'm a guy I don't I don't
see the problem
don't you like babies what is wrong with
you you don't like baby an eggplant is
stuck in my bellybutton health will just
poop it
out or ask someone else to poop it out
god I got my dick stuck in a tree um
just cut it off the tree the tree not
your well you know what you might do do
whatever you want I don't care what is
this what what is I wanted to help you
bros I don't think you're serious
all right next one my dick is stuck in
the dish what god damn it you're
probably spinning around like crazy then
our jaw how did you even tweet this you
just you don't take me seriously dick
got stuck in a sandwich next my dick is
stuck in a god damn it my day my
dick got stuck in a ceiling fan and now
it's on fire bull just be on it I got my
dick stuck in the toaster well don't pee
on it you'll get electrocuted my dick is
stuck in a blender how could you know
what that I'm done I'm done you had your
chance all right that was purely
problems hopefully it helps you feel
free to tweet me your problems and I'll
help them in the next one
if you enjoyed this episode please bros
go ahead and leave a like every time you
like you save the problem of a duck so
go ahead and do it help a back you
schmuck now I'm just kidding I also
wanted to say thank you bros so much for
showing your support with me turning off
the comments a lot of people didn't
understand but those of you who did I
mean it's been overwhelmingly nice for
me because I've been getting more
support than ever and it's been really
heartwarming and really nice so it meant
a lot to me Rose and I felt like I
really need it so thank you that's all
for me for now as always stay awesome
Rose is a breakfast for you
yeah